[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who loves to
put a smile on that face and this video
we're breaking down barracky owens
version of the joker appearing at the
end of the batman heavily cloaked in
shadow he very much teases what could be
happening in the next film and though
his appearance lasts less than a minute
he's a big talking point when you come
out of the movie matt reeves has
discussed the character in a bit more
depth than what we got in the film and
it's helped to flesh out his take and
also the basis for it this includes a
number of comics films and lots of
things that we can look at to guess
where it's all going throughout this
video we're going to be breaking all
down but if you enjoy it then hit that
thumbs up button like you've got a
crowbar and it's jason todd's head don't
forget to subscribe as wear your ace in
the hole when it comes to videos
discussing all the latest comic book
movies and without the way let's get
into the video
okay so it seems like every other year
we get a different version of the joker
there's been jared leto barry keown and
if you think you'll be the last of them
then you must be joaquin like joaquin
phoenix like like juaquin phoenix it
looks better written down anyway he's
one of the most iconic characters of all
time and though we've had many versions
that have come and gone we all know that
gotham loves a comeback now much in the
same way that batman begins ending with
a teaser the clown prince of crime the
batman does too we find him in a cell
beside the riddler and though we can't
fully see his face we can tell that he's
heavily scarred and we want to know how
he got him how we got them how do you
get them scores now this is way more cut
than lege's incarnation and it actually
has basis in the creation of the
character when developing the villain
bob kane and bill finger based him
heavily on the 1928 film the man who
laughs this featured a man who had a
richest grin across his entire face that
he was unable to get rid of the man who
laughs title was later referenced in the
batman book of the same name which
centered around batman's first showdown
with the clown prince of crime
interestingly he killed several
high-ranking citizens of gotham
attempted a murder bruce wayne and try
to destroy the reservoir in order to
flood the city which is something that
reeves might have looked at for his
story of the batman however in an
interview with ign he did talk about how
the silent film and very much the roots
of the character influenced his take i
wanted to create an iteration of him
that felt distinctive and new but went
right back to the roots so he he's kind
of very much out of the conrad vite sort
of mold and that idea of the silent film
of the man who laughs he's got this
congenital disease he can never stop
smiling and i was like well
maybe there's something here where it's
not something where he fell in a vat of
chemicals or it's not the nolan thing
where he has these scars and we don't
know where they came from what if this
is something that he's been touched on
that he's been touched by from birth and
that he has a kind of congenital disease
that refuses to let him stop smiling and
he's had this very dark reaction to it
and it's made him he's had to spend a
life of people looking at him in a
certain way and he knows how to get into
your head so this idea of him being
very kind of incisive and brilliant and
being able to get into your mind and
having basically having this kind of
nihilistic point of view that sort of
like from his inception from his birth
life has been a cruel joke on him and
this is his response and he's eventually
going to become
declare himself as a clown declare
himself as the joker so lots of things
that we can take from that and i love
the idea that he's just constantly
smiling no matter what
one of the most unnerving things about
the jokerism grinning through some of
the most terrifying things ever and
there's several crimes that he's
committed over the years which have been
made even more horrific because he's
cackled away to himself whilst carrying
them out another interesting aspect that
reeves touched upon is also his ability
to get inside of the minds of anyone who
looks at him they're of course
fascinated with his grin and he's able
to gauge their expressions in order to
get inside their heads this is something
that the joker is known for on the
comics and there's even been moments
where he's talked inmates and arkham
into killing themselves just because he
was annoyed by the person in the cell
next to him i think that this is very
much reflected in the scene with the
riddler that he has at the end of the
movie now when we first meet the joker
the prisoner drops his own riddle just
for the villain he says riddle me this
the less of these you have the more one
is worth the answer is friends and it
seems like going forward that the two
will be pairing up however there's also
a neat psychological trick here that
yoga pulls and he's very much taking
riddler under his wing rather than
seeing him as an equal sure he's a
friend but you could look into it that
by him taking the idea of a riddle and
then using it to strike up a friendship
with the riddler that he has power over
the character nareevs also brought the
fact that he intended to use the joker
in another scene earlier in the movie
because the movie is not an origin tale
for batman but it's his early days it
really is an origin tale for the rogues
galleries the reason that joker's in the
movie is there was actually another
scene that was earlier the scene that
was not in the movie the scene that this
is really the companion to um which is
actually a really cool scene that i that
will release at some point it it's a
scene where batman is so unnerved
because the riddler is writing to him
and
he's like why is this guy writing to me
and he figures he's got to profile
this killer and so he goes to see
another killer that he's clearly had an
experience with in these first two years
and this killer in this story is
not yet the character that we come to
know right so everybody's in their kind
of infancy so you know in in the comics
these characters often declare their
alter egos in in response to the fact
that there's a batman out there he
further touched upon this in an
interview with cinema blend there's
another arkham scene that involves um
the unseen prisoner that you see uh near
the end of the movie and it batman goes
to him in order to profile the riddler
because he's being written to one of the
lines from the scene that's not in is
that unseen prisoner says to him he says
it's almost our anniversary isn't it and
you realize that there's a they have a
relationship that exists before that
character who is the character that you
think he is so we know that batman would
have confronted the man who would become
the joker very early on in his career
with this being a year 2 story it makes
sense that it would have happened in the
first one and the joker has always been
someone who's been introduced at the
start of batman's career whether it's
year one his time with the redhood gang
in zero yeah or the man who laughs these
are all events that take place around
the first 365 days of the batman's rise
in gotham i love the way that matt
describes him as not really being the
joker yet and it's only when batman
becomes fully formed that they do too
now he touched upon his origins the
psychology behind the character and also
his past with batman but what about his
feature well reeves has said that he's
not currently planning on using the
joker in the sequel for the film and
whilst this might be a lie to avoid
spoilers there are other ways that he
could pop up we did originally have an
announcement that a gcpd show would be
coming soon however reef has stated that
this has now evolved into an arkham
asylum series i think that this would be
the perfect way to not only discuss the
joker's origin story but it could also
give him a jumping off point to pop up
in a future movie with the character's
face being highly scarred it also
somewhat opens the door for a death in
the family version of the villain in
that story he cuts his face off at the
start and then wears it as a mask the
guy was absolutely terrifying because of
this and he'd flip the face around so
that his eye was poking through the
mouth and so on and so forth there's
lots of things that they can do with the
character and i'd love to see them
heading in that direction there's also
the possibility that we get the war of
jokes and riddles in which the two sides
go head to head in a battle that spans
gotham with it being submerged
underwater after the riddler's attack we
know that the criminals are all going to
be vying for control and not only will
this allow characters like the penguin
to take a shot but it could also allow
for the joker too there's lots of
interesting ways it can go and obviously
i'd love to hear your thoughts on what
you think's gonna happen i know there's
people that also love the new joker
people that hate him and people are
interested in what's gonna happen so let
me know below hopefully you enjoyed the
video and if you leave a comment you'll
be entered into a competition this month
where we're giving away three copies of
spiderman no way home and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the film we
pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the witness of the last
one on screen right now say that to you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the batmobile scene
which will be linked on screen right
here right now we go over all the horror
inspirations that matt reeves pulled
from why it looks so cool and yeah
definitely go check it out right after
this by the way thanks for sticking
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you in the next one take care peace